the only reason I agreed to a
traditional wedding was because you said
that we'd have moments alone
Carol
hi hello
your future mother-in-law Cara if I know
your name Carol I brought some of the
extras for the welcome bags in case you
want to make one for Sean oh oh great
thanks all right thanks call me she's
not wearing any pants
I just want to ask and I hope it's okay
is that genetics
or is it like Pilates your mom now's not
the time
[Music]
oh Darcy I am so honored to Bear witness
to the sacred observance of rebirth and
devotion
team thank you Renata
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey me too when I'm in formal wear I
like to pee standing up how about you
my name
is Carol Elaine Fowler
and I deserve to live
Carol
what are you doing I'm humanizing myself
I saw it on Good Morning America if you
humanize yourself to them
they let you live
I am a wife
I am a mother
and I was Milford Michigan's top realtor
in 1998
and again in 2007
I dreamed of going to Ireland I was a
late bloomer and my teeth didn't come in
till I was 14. please pick me
[Music]
I'm from Brazil
I have a beautiful hair
[Music]
what else
you're a mother
I'm a mother
you doing okay Jamie
my stomach feels like it's gonna fall to
my [ __ ] but otherwise I'm chilling
listen it's normal to feel scared I'm
not gonna let anything happen to you
or your family I promise
hey Sean
I am also feeling scared like the most
scared I've ever been in my whole life
it's like I just watched the ring you
know